التقدم بالسن يعني اكتساب خبره اكثر نقطه
ارتكاز دفاع رئيسه بكيت جو بايدن عن قراره
الترشح لولايه ثانيه بعد تجاوزه عتبه
الثمانين عاما الترشح ثم امكانيه الفوز
يعني ان بايدن سيؤدي اليمين دستوريه في
عمر يناهز 82 عاما وسيكون اقرب الى
التسعينات بحلول نهايه فترته ثانيه بايدن
مدافعا عن قراره اكد انه يعرف اكثر من
الغالبيه العظمى من الناس وانه الاكثر
خبره من اي شخص سبق له الترشح للمنصب ويجد
نفسه فاعلا
ومشرفا وفق صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه
علما بان استطلاعا للراي اجري الشهر
الماضي اظهر ان 70% من الامريكيين لا
يؤيدون ترشيح بايدن لولايه ثانيه مع
تاكيدهم ان عامل العمر المؤثر الاكبر
برايهم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات